after this huge success
i mean we gotta do something about
season two right so it will come out i
believe it will come up but just i
i don't know yet you know how and when
will come out but it will come out
eventually
[Music]
[Music]
squid game has become such a huge
success with american audiences what has
the fan reaction been like for you were
you expecting this much attention
to
which game was the most difficult for
you guys to film and which one was your
favorite to film
we ended season one on a big cliffhanger
and we saw your character not go on the
plane what does this mean could there be
a season two of squid games
of brainstorming
yeah i mean
after this huge success
i mean we gotta do something about
agents right so it will come out i
believe it will come up but just i i
don't know yet you know how and when
will come out but it will come out
eventually sounds like season two is
happening would you come back what would
you like to see
cooking is
i promise
[Music]
you